Toronto New York Nashville San Francisco
Chennai his fanbase has come out in full
force and not only is she still the one
looks like she's going to be number one
[Music]
celebrating on a Late Late Show music
insiders say Shania will sell her on 129
to 134 thousand albums in her first week
including streams that's an impressive
number considering she's been away from
the busy years and is up against Miley
Cyrus and Demi Lovato
[Music]
deme who performed on Ellen today to
ramp up more sales will take the second
spot on the Billboard chart with an
estimated 68 to 73 thousand copies sold
while Miley will grab fourth place with
47 to 50 mm not exactly the best number
considering she's even doing an entire
residency on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon this week to get people Pumped Up
she's so fun she plays she's the nicest
everyone she hangs with this is the
nicest and such a great vibe and she's a
she's just like I think you're
professional but you're a very
perfectionist and I love those types of
guests I think they're my favorite type
of people q Timberlake he basically said
I'm his favorite